I have a lot of cramping in my legs and sometimes my big toe. What could be the problem
besides magnesium and mineral deficiency? So you're right. The first thing you think of
is leg cramping and your toe cramping is magnesium, mineral deficiency, iron deficiency are all
things. However, there's another thing that can be common with muscle cramping in your legs,
which hardly anybody thinks about. It can be tied to food allergies as well. I know some patients
that have gluten sensitivities that kind of fall off the wagon and start eating gluten again,
and they end up with cramping and or pain in their lower extremities. That's not an uncommon
thing as well. I would do take-backs with epsom salts could be helpful. Those are the kind of things
that you look for. At a blood test, make sure that your iron isn't really low or you're at your
really adiabic as well.